hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to five weird games we're
gonna be starting with a game called the
ant basset err where you are an
ambassador watch just here okay let's go
for this one this is a game ah never
mind don't let it explain itself the
Ambassador he seized on our favor and
cement the uneasy peace between us our
fate lies in his hand if he plays it
well he could bring our worlds together
[Music]
[Laughter]
gasp at all sir this is the ambassador
oh I don't like the way that fingy oh
boy hoppity hippity hoppity excuse me
official and capacity business
hail ambassador I would give thee a
feast but mine crate is stuck well fear
not my finger shall poke the truth out
my god finger a little problematic oh
yeah blessed be the Queen I'll just take
my pittance of an apple for you to fit
alright
on my way doodlee do work work work work
work work hail and bassett earth or
taking the gates were switching ceremony
and open the doors to Aunt dopey up you
the Pope
let's go Pat alright sure I'm gonna
switch us watch this oh my god dad how
do I curl my [ __ ] or my fingy
we've got turret curl this way with
with my clicky clicky okay I'm gonna
click it okay girl okay hang on curl no
still move forward when you Carl move oh
you're a tricky one like opening a saudi
poppy good did some with goochy goochy
goo all over your Gucci Gucci come on
give me a Gucci give me a - cheeky
goochie goochie goo
I like there's no ceremony I'm a
layabout blessed be the Queen all right
sorry a fine entrance though you shan't
be able to make a second um sorry
where's my hat what is my job I cannot
know without it Oh what is my job what
is my purpose without a hat I have Oh
forsooth I am so blessed be the queen
okay let me review the controls real
quick so you guys know what kind of hell
I'm in I lift up the mouse it goes up
and then it flops back down so I have to
have this constant like upward motion if
I want to stay up II won't be tied the
Sun my fiery arch what did you say my
fiery arch nemesis may we wore a whop on
whoa geez geez that's a little that's a
little much huh my word these soldiers
have begun a terrible row I'm sorry I am
sorry I didn't mean to do that okay just
go ahead oh my god I'm sorry I'm not
it's not on purpose I'm just trying to
like scoop your hat off of you I'm not
trying to kill you
these soldiers have begun a terrible row
so I will knock their hats off okay very
daintily goochie goochie goochie goochie
goochie goochie goochie
these hands they can only kill goochie
okay good Jade goats go cheek okay
good Chi goochy goochy goochy goochy
just a nice little hop murderer goochie
goochie goochie goochie goochie
okay please please
good thing I explained how the controls
are [ __ ] whoa okay how is your hat
still up no no I will not kill I will
not kill again okay he said last blessed
be something or other
[Music]
hail ambassador Queen Antoinette awaits
excuse moi
escucha mu Qi cursed like in ambassador
your kingdom cannot be trusted I would
cast the out if it were my right okay
fair enough all right
well Matt ambassador word of your good
deeds has reached my aunt na this era of
peace was hard-fought we must seal our
newfound allegiance by common blood I'm
ready mother marry princess Anastasia
and taste Asia anta stasia ground her as
your queen I don't want to have to opt
Rena think of the word it's not
commemorate it's not commiserate
consummate that's the one I don't want
to [ __ ] aunt
basically because what I'm trying to say
here I uh how do i how do i scooch it
through okay that's not all
sorry i'm trying not to screw Shu I
swear I'm okay how am I gonna Gucci
scoochie this okay hey God I just gonna
just got a pokey woky it it's kind of
whoa okay God got some progress made
okey-dokey
this is not a preview events to come
later on when we woo hey whoa hang on
okay how do i oh oh if I right-click I
keep it pokey whoa key no I don't that's
lie that was a lie
ah oh there's gonna be hell I'll get all
right I'm sorry I'm sorry okay let me
listen listen to what you have to say
well Matt Oh
what uh what a beautiful princess you
have I can't move it yet I'll just rest
my finger here I brandy bother okay sure
you are with the this crown I duty Wed
this I oppose this union highway and
doneö you name and the stage' belongs on
our own kin I still remember the scars
of war and the destruction Assante that
bastard or Rose rot on our people it has
haunted me for years
Antonio you were born last week but duel
is it a bad day um yeah let me let me
just let me swoop some knowledge in down
from on high listen there's gonna be a
crash zoom listen buddy you have never
[ __ ] with anyone as hurricane Ashley
destructive as me you and your kind
would be a stain on my
our peace has indeed been sealed by
blood I pray it is the last drop - now
let us greet aunt Opie as the new royal
family okay Oh Edward
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay so that was aunt bass adore oh that
was fun though
that was fun I do love like these
physically enabled weird games like
those are the best games cuz you just
have no idea what you're gonna be doing
then poor aunt Toni Oh hilariously named
but poor Antonia just misguided just
misguided oh well what can you do
oh it's it oh it's a two-player game all
right well I'll play with myself lost in
space i j k l + enter I can do
two-player I could probably do this okay
alright oh no oh no oh no I am so lonely
I need I don't what am i wait what am i
wait what's the objective oh there oh we
I need this one
ha I'm beating myself hey guys look I'm
beating myself yeah I'm so good at this
Oh me got it too late buddy oh you think
you're good it's like which one of my
eyes is gonna see the right wait wait
that was it no no oh that was not it
okay
this was it that was it wait that was it
this just that one no no that was it
though neither of my hands are working
that way oh that no that was it no that
was uh Frick me this there we go I got
it alright okay alright
mr. secondhand got it oh good old righty
righty
I love you righty you know I love you
hmm you're so special to me
you need to step it up a lot cuz I like
I I need you to understand that this is
important for me so don't [ __ ] it up
don't [ __ ] it up sorry I love you okay
let's try that again yeah that was good
all right now like I got my coordination
goin on it wait wait yes yes yeah okay
Lefty good job lofty
oh you got that good oh no that's a
trick that's a trick that ain't it no
right he knows better than that
the left he's lookin left he's lookin
real close
lefty lefties right righty all righty is
really showing up a storm
ready ready no no lefties swoop it in ha
ready you get one chance and you failed
you suck ass the lefties looking more
and more specially today
okay all right oh oh hey oh my god I
always knew that you could do it you
know I always believed in you you know I
always believed in you Lefty
I always knew that you were the most
special the most incredibly well shaped
formerly and beautiful righty you [ __ ]
it up
what did I tell Lefty you were there
don't act like you weren't there you
were there and you disappointed me
I believed in you I believed it
now kiss oh wait wait no wait guys wait
no I I can change I can be better but
you'd be better than this
ah that's an awkward time to cut the
music off okay all right well um you
okay re I'll get it
can you just delete that like all that
everything that I can you delete that no
once all right okay all right anyway
there we go all right welcome to godly
Corp demo I don't know why scientists on
the zombie virus that appeared just two
weeks ago they released information
saying that the symptoms to watch for
armed aggression foaming from the mouth
and deterioration of motor skills and an
unbelievable hunger be advised that if
an infected becomes hostile the only way
to harm them is to shoot them in the
head good to know okay so
[Music]
and illusion on the rise you can see the
that will display instructions for your
task and in the center is about MIT you
can press when you are ready to start
your shift that leaves with the
instructions and remaining cover from
the button and press it to star good
luck okay alright make sure all crucial
points on this planet get enough heat
also you might run into some bugs don't
let them affect the planet some kind of
Cthulhu thing going on here and I'm not
100% sure I'm into it but uh yeah let's
uh let's Oh
let's flip this up and let's get oh I'm
trying to listen I'm I'm I'm trying to
oh did I hit it
oh okay let's go to South Amer oh wait
no wait what is South America oh wait no
wait what south of what oh wait a minute
oh oh oh [ __ ] amiss
oh it's a heat lamp and I have to this
is the game hey whoa whoa hi get oh get
out of here
get out of here alright so Antarctica
needs some heat I guess which is kind of
weird this is the gate this is the game
get out of here where am I okay this way
I don't think Antarctica needs that much
heat but all right
oh boy yeah yeah Oh this is not Asia
wait where's Asia oh there's Asia I'm
sorry
[ __ ] uh it's hard to control yeah
[ __ ] it's oh my brain my brain okay
South American KITT get out it where's
my goai where am I
okay Jesus oh my god oh my god oh my god
I can't I can't do this
get out get out okay so I got to think
of it it's from the perspective of the
heat lamp that's what the perspective it
what is that supposed to be
why who did that what does someone
pulling a prank on me
good god this tentacle doesn't work just
no no no no no I said no this doesn't
make any sense I don't get it and I
don't understand my tentacle is stuck
okay thank you I did it I did it I'm
average all that work all that stress
everything that I was doing and I'm
average okay I'm kind of dumb but I know
I get it Oh what is that I know really I
really don't know no way I just I need
this I how many well how that I'm
touching it with I'm I'm really touching
this thing Oh
thank you please give me another thank
you very much thank God [ __ ] Oh can I
have another can you bring another one
in thank you that's what I would
appreciate just drop it into my tentacle
that'd be great okay grab two CH I I'm
left clicking literally I can't one more
please one more bottle of water please
give me one more
oh God look I'm touch I left click I
click and hold it doesn't do either it
doesn't work this doesn't work it
obviously doesn't work maybe I can't
grab it until I start it maybe I can't
grab it until I start it tick tock goes
the clock indeed okay can I grab it now
can i grab it can i grab it now can i
grab it can i grab it can i grab it now
could i grab it now how about now grab
come on now grab how about now grab how
about how about oh my god I want to grab
it so badly just grab me
how'd that happen how'd you get your
tentacles stuck wrap around the start
button yeah funny about that it would be
amazing if you gave me thumbs okay grab
and no grab alright no grab a Red Alert
[Music]
[Applause]
dude I cannot pick though I can't pick
anything up I can't I can't
alright you know I would if I could I I
would if I could I would also the mouse
goes outside the game which everyone
knows my favorite okay I don't know
what's happening I can't click on I
can't grab it I can't grab it if I can't
grab it helmet if I could grab this oh
boy
that looks fun if I could just if I
could just grab it's right mouse it's
right mouse button I get s'right mouse
button it's right it's not left it's
right oh my god oh my god oh oh it's oh
wow it's right oh that's funny
Oh dance it's oh it's it's not left it's
right it's right mouse button the
instructions were we're very wrong the
instructions oh I wish they were Carell
it's not working what the hell the hell
what why what am i what am i what wait
what what it's been our but it's not
what is that but it's not but it's not
you see how it's not um working it's uh
okay I think I can do it you got a spray
and while they're alive or else they're
just gonna die which should have been
obvious I guess but some are gonna die
no matter what I did oh that's different
oh that's interesting I didn't expect
that to go that way but okay alright
this is fine I'm not spraying behind it
I'm not that's a lie they don't lie
you wouldn't lie to me oh I was spraying
[Music]
okay all right now I'm now I'm into this
game
whoa that's okay now this games gotten
way more fun this this game pretty good
that's pretty good okay you know I had
my reservations about this game but this
is clearly one of the best games ever
made now I see it I see it I see it now
I can see the quality built into every
every single pour of this game I got it
the tentacle weirded me out at first but
now now I'm into it now I know exactly
what I'm doing and I can keep these bad
boys alive till the end of time but only
the instructions were perfect is this
what the security breach is is this
really what the security breach is all
about okay now it's funny now that I'm
less angry and now that I'm spraying in
the right place there's good stuff
there's good stuff oh hell yeah
there we go I love this game this game's
good this good game good game good game
I better get up above average
yah yah wah hoo whee an excellent all
right good good okay do I even want to
keep going with this really build a
planet from the available pieces green
hologram shows next piece needed once in
place central screen will show you what
tool to use to place this thing in
repeat until the plans complete also
protect the second planet from incoming
me okay okay thank you
all right I have a piece where we wait
wait have a nice what oh okay
got one I think what do I need to get it
in place you get out of the way please
glue okay glue glue glue glue no no glue
glue glue glue glue glue
got it okay all right you are you the
one is this the one no okay this one no
not that this one oh this is like
surgery simulator in space this is this
one no it's it's got to be that yeah oh
yeah give me that hey where's a hammer
give me the ham ho come here ham ho big
bong Bing bong big box please Punk pink
but why is this spinning in my can't
that doesn't make any goddamn sense no
shoot
wait shoot shoot shoot shoot oh okay
hammer
give me the hammer guy the way got this
hammer I got the hammer get it boom ba
boom ba ba ba ba
okay got a shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot
shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot
shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot give
me the hammer
I hit it once I hit it once really that
was one hit getting hammered give me a
hammer ba ba ba ba ba okay glue it now
glue why do I got
okay all right who's next
you know maybe ya know god damn it okay
this one yeah that was it okay hammer oh
shoot shoot shoot blam blam blam blam
blam blam blam I don't understand how
this is working or what kind of office
is able to shoot in the space and also
have a laser system I am running out of
time give to me got it got it got it
okay give me another one come on shut up
I don't not the point right now oh come
on there we go there we go come on
hammer Hammer hammer shoot shoot shoot
shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot
shooting okay Hammer hammer Hammer
hammer come on hammer it houses not
hammering okay there we go
that's good okay oh okay we're good got
the last one and flap okay
hammer it give me that I don't know how
this is actually building a new planet
this really bizarre
why I don't understand
I don't care what's happening I have no
idea what's going on and I don't know
why and I'm scared that's good hey
Karthik just so long as stressful why
does it do that is there anything left
is there any oh oh that's the end of it
okay so I wish I was [ __ ] talking it a
bit there but this is one of those games
that's intentionally meant to be
frustrating it reminds me of amputee
more than it reminds me a surgeon
simulator it reminds me of amputee which
was the first game after surgeon
simulator to kind of like copy that
format if any of you any of you remember
me playing amputee that's what this one
kind of reminds me of and it's super
weird that it does but it really really
does like it really honestly truly does
it's super weird but not bad I like it
it's it's meant to be weird it's meant
to be a little difficult
there is potential here I mean this kind
of thing isn't like it's not totally
original but it is something interesting
so I liked it it was pretty good I liked
I liked it oh all right so this game um
I don't know
but with a name like shark simulator you
cannot avoid it I don't know how the
game goes I don't know how the game
mechanic is I don't know if there's a
story and I don't care I don't care when
you get something like shark simulator
that just pops into your lap you play it
you don't ask questions you just play it
and you go from there and life is just
better for it you just don't question a
goddamn thing about it oh my god Oh
shift control to move up Oh president I
am due back flip wait no back flip wait
up and down knee up and the down II I
think this is something like a back flip
oh my god I love it I love it I am
upside down I am upside my goal is to
kill 50 people oh yes it is of course it
would be of course oh why am I just
[Laughter]
space to jump yum-yum-yum Oh hold eat
open your job blah I'm gonna go eat some
people I can't stop spinning for some
reason oh well what can you do
anyway I got 50 people you know it's
recorded you might diet yeah he's gonna
be fine
yeah wait I I do some flips we [ __ ] that
didn't go so well coming up tried to
talk to some researcher came by and saw
this shirt blah blah blah maybe you're
okay wait let me go down go up ha
jump why I did not work at all I'm gonna
get people somehow bomb okay ah here we
go
all right sorry sorry about that moment
um num num is this food this is what you
would call food hey officer I'm not
doing nothing just in this chair
I'm no right way now ow
why oh ow help ow ow ow ow no I'm gonna
butcher ow Oh rude I was just trying to
have a nice snack on a chair Oh once you
start moving just don't stop moving
Oh Oh perfect Oh perfect how did I kill
four people don't kill four people
what does like you do not kill four
people I can't even imagine doing that
l-'azim sucks something so dastardly so
devilish I can't even be one that
remotely thinks about that anyway just
look at me flapping my gums over here
I'll tell you the story about how I got
into this predicament known as laughs
well you know I was born and outraged
and of harm down under water excuse me
got a little laryngitis anyway oh farm
and I just like those is you one of the
one of the guys but then you know life
comes at you fast
if you can't adapt to life then you
can't adapt to anything so I'm just
gonna make my way downtown moving fast
faces may pass or they may not but I'm
homebound no matter what excuse me can I
munch on your tuchus as I was saying I
was just going about my own business not
minded nothing and then all the sudden I
found myself in the jaws of justice you
mind if I'll give you a little munch you
look like a tasty treat that can't be
beat you mind if I just who you are
soulless oh my oh my oh my ba ba ba ba
demons nibbling on the back of the neck
there Oh gah get out here oh geez oh
geez oh geez oh geez oh gosh oh geez I'm
sorry
I'm sorry that's my bad my bad I'm gonna
kill ten people I killed one I killed
one people all right time to play this
game for real nom nom nom
nom nom nom are you new come here come
here I think like just incidentally I
end up killing more people than it seems
come here come here
no no no come here why are you doing
we're done why you're trying to trying
to get away gotcha
I got out oh no no not again
ow ow Chism's I'll just try ask you
sorry I'm just trying to live man man
these guys are good you're [ __ ] what
do we do with money what kind of shirt
what's your shirt gonna do with money
alright you know I'm just gonna try to
like speed my way through life cuz I
don't think I'm gonna be able to do it
oh my god how much speed can I pick up
here okay alright okay none if I hit
that we're really getting speared now
man why would I ever go underwater I get
so much more speed out here on land and
I just need to pick up enough speed get
up oh god damn it
here we go this looks like a nice long
stretch get some speed going is what I'm
talking about
oh yes okay oh [ __ ] god damn it
larry was are you alright this seems
like the longest stretch of road I might
get so let's go for it let's gun it okay
come on come on oh no oh no oh no oh oh
hit a billboard okay that's a problem
you shooting me why I got two frames hey
come on now don't be ridiculous I'm
stuck oh god I'm stuck
help help I don't wanna be like Larry oh
god I've got no friends don't kill me
don't kill me oh please won't live
there's one more day of sweet life as I
take life from others plays oh God
okay better frames all of a sudden oh no
no I nom skewers BAE I want to get my
objective at least well there aren't
that many people in this city er you
think though a little bit more but
apparently not what about what about the
dock workers union anybody down there
want to get munched and crunched what's
this blue wait put on the shark brakes
let's wiggle our way over here whatever
the hell is going on
delivery deliver all the packages if at
what Oh
oh all right okay let's do this
Oh
oh you've gotta be [ __ ] oh no oh no
oh oh that's oh well screw that Oh screw
that so hard I'm not doing that
screw that you're not gonna give me a
shark backpack to put that on
maybe a short jetpack shark jetpack
shark pack pardon me
can't really control it Oh can't I'm
coming for this guy this guy is so dunzo
damn it I missed no I missed all the
delicious Oh kitties I just want and all
my other missions gone oh well screw it
oh girl for you oh my god before your
buddy I'm coming for you oh I'll get you
I will get you oh you think you can run
just cuz I can't seem to move anymore
alright well if you guys don't like my
shark acrobatics my shark batiks then
I'm not gonna be here for you anymore
hello I think I've sucked every possible
ounce of fun of this game and I don't
know what to do with the money so yeah I
think I'm just done but I guess I'm done
patch notes there are costumes leave
bowling area exited noir added cost
where do you get costumes where do I
wait I can get costumes for my shark
well don't get that what do I get that
when were you gonna tell me that okay
hang on maybe I haven't sucked every
ounce of oh there's a funfair oh well I
gotta go to the funfair
alright hang on I ain't gonna bother
nobody I just want costumes up at this
costumes at the funfair oh it is a fun
fair it's fun fair carnival the carnival
fun fair the fun fair carve I'll all go
on the ferris wheel the fun wheel the
fun fair fun wheel that's what they call
it fun fair branded fun with ski
mountain not killing nobody I ain't
killing no by Swarovski land nobody
after what happened to Larry I ain't
gonna let that Avenue move
doors but I don't want to kill you
I could I could very quickly and easily
but I don't want to kill you I'm going
to a funfair the Foreign Fair where the
fun never ends and the fairies price far
and fair to a far and fair quite long
road do go to the fun fair hello can i
won now one ticket please
carousel ride a horse and have fun at
the funfair funk oh wow
well looks a bit like we're having an
intimate moment here the only way as I
was saying I gave up killing people
because of what happened to my cousin
Larry
he got mounted on the side of a fish
shop can you imagine that can you
imagine that
where anyway it looks like I look
straight up like this shark is [ __ ]
that horse hey down boy I would fun Oh
so far no shark hunter no way that's so
scary oh my god Larry Larry Larry Larry
looks like Larry got an upgrade from
last time a Larry okay all right shark
honor or it is you see you myron hey
lady you myron Hey look I'm a real shark
look at my dick look at my shark dick
right here right there there it is sorry
is this inappropriate okay anyway our
mouth yay a shark coaster let me just
down
what kind of ride attendant allowed me
on this machine I don't even know it
would be better if the roll goes was
shark in the coaster itself ok dodgems
Oh what is that that's a mission circle
what is the mission what mission we talk
about here human cannonball jump on the
trampoline to catch a flying human Oh
so this is just like this is just oh hi
oh oh oh I didn't know where how was it
how was it oh [ __ ] yeah thank you
oh god damn it oh um we are so big what
the hell she's so big what is it you and
so big it was gigantic it's a matter of
perspective
holy crap yeah oh I got you huh
get you right baby balls here we go oh
no all right by your noggin all right by
your big dumb noggin I don't want to do
it don't do it again here we go Oh nom
gotcha so you could get away from me
giant humo how'd you fit in that cannon
that doesn't even make any sense
Oh boink go right by your gourd bowling
hey cousin let's go bowling
cousin Larry oh he's dead I forgot about
that fourth cousin oh I think it was a
bit late late to the hibbity yeah I was
a bit late on that one all right goodbye
I mean he's gonna die anyway because you
crash into the coaster and then whole
thing's gonna come down and everybody's
gonna be mad at me okay I don't know if
I got enough air on this one nope missed
it by that much
Oh best times gonna be there friend good
oh well okay I was different but not oh
okay what is even the point
why is even the point Oh buckaroos it's
basically this is good simulator I
didn't even realize it when I was first
playing it that this is just basically
goat something oh you're not even gonna
resent me over there okay I gotta walk
all the way back okay the first with the
big wheel you're Marv and the big excuse
me
you Myron the big wheel here
oh good oh good okay okay okay oh god oh
god oh god oh good one more one more one
more one more
okay okay one more time Oh God
okay okay god no okay all right bumper
cars okay where's bumper cars okay what
costumes that's what I was going for I'm
disappointed by the bumper cars but
costumes you know what to do with your
money spend it on these outrageously
expensive costumes
oh yeah clownfish clownfish pirate Oh
armor
spider shark these are do expensive why
are they so expensive I'm not gonna play
this game long enough to get that I
wasted ten minutes on the ferris wheel
hang on okay overshot my bowling all
right cousin here we go throw yourself
and wreck those pins apart you got it Oh
what thought three points right hop
no points what what seven points
I get it cuz in bowling you get hope you
get two tries that makes sense but why
why what the why why what what the hell
ah oh no no don't know we was falling
you [ __ ] okay that one just is an iron
pen it just never falls okay that's a
strike
that's a strike Oh a spare sorry spare
how though you would never get a strike
in this there's no way you could never
get a strike there's no way you never
get a strike that was the most horrible
experience of my entire life I'm going
back to [ __ ] that horse okay I'm
gonna miss you a silly game I can see
how you get a little fun out of it but
it's over real quick whoa whoa okay
about here see ya
so this is spill tender you're a
bartender and you need to give your
patrons some drinks simple as that okay
all right Oh dah dah dah dah dah dah dah
dah dah dah oh no oh this isn't a ha ha
ha how does that work I'm hot doing it
as hard as it can hot it up
oh I gotta get in in the light okay no
why is it over there
what no I'm not trying to put it over
there I'm trying to spank the monkey try
to wheel it up so I can Whangdoodle it
okay thank you I guess
all right whatever you stupid jackasses
what that was right in your palm
you tell me you don't want there you go
okay I mean I've got these stupid beers
that are sitting off over here I made it
okay goddamn that wasn't for goddamn
peanut
last call ha da-da-da-da-da the
deadliest hunted oh [ __ ]
god dammit ha da ba da oh god damn the
peanuts
alright well that sucked but I think I
did okay beer served nine accuracy 41
percent faster serve one second
beers wasted $18 I made no money and her
initials mmm [ __ ] okay so [ __ ] had $10
so this is all the game is oh I see wait
that guy was thirsty but now is was
light's gone but this doesn't make I am
fling doodling it as how do i oh my god
they're controlled I the shards of glass
really the shards of glass are the ones
that oh boy it's like this game was
meant to be controlled by a finger and I
don't have the Finke meant for okay you
know what I guess no one's getting beer
now I was doing better when I didn't
know how to play I mean I still don't
know how to play but hold it or hold it
I hope you didn't want peanuts how am I
supposed to even get them to you if you
don't you better drink that look hot a
dog that drink into your heart of gob
shove it okay there you go ha bad dog
there you go buddy okay now I'm getting
the hang of it yeah ha ha
can I get like bullet time or something
like that beer time here's your beer Tom
there's a beer Tom yep bubble bubble is
it beer time well [ __ ] I did worse than
I did last time how the Frick did I do
worse I did last time you're fired
well [ __ ] alright god damn you [ __ ]
making me look bad if it goes right to
their hand they drink it okay well I
can't get you down there there's peanuts
in the way I'm just that's for you later
this is for you later you know what I
mean no that's gonna make it yeah grab
it with your okay okay
ha ba da here's another one okay so I
just can't be stupid about
flea like most things in my life it
would work if I just wasn't incredibly
stupid about it ha
no that's peanuts huh well that guy's
getting loaded up with beers something
about him just makes me think alcoholics
so I just kept shoving beers down his
gob as hard as they could
no get it was right that you have a beer
okay you had a beer but now you don't
have a beer and now you do have a beer
now you have a beer beer for you a beer
for you
double beer down there that technically
went on you so it was yours so you pay
money for that
alright fine well I did better than I
did before but I don't know if I feel
good about it
ass alright alright so ass [ __ ] so ass
and [ __ ] ya haba daba caba daba shut the
hell up hobbit doll poor boy you have a
deeper voice than you had before I'm
assuming the beer did something to that
effect hobbit da also can I talk about
the nightmares that are these characters
like the absolute oh no oh come on why
are you breaking what are you breaking
is it too hard okay you know I can't
help you if you're not actually gonna
help me pick up the goddamn beer hobo
door you got it buddy I'm here for you I
live to serve you jackasses hobbit da
Hobbit debo No wide the trip
it's a goddamn penis it's an O you eat
if I don't shove glass into the black
gaping holes of your eyes okay so ass
[ __ ] me is the leaderboard energy as it
stands right now why did you kick the
peanuts please no peanut get it grab it
grab it grab it
rabbit firmly ground oh you [ __ ] one
buff please give one Hobbit ah for my
Baba ha I think I think my trick is I
don't need to let go I'm letting go of
the mouse I know how to play this game
now okay that made no sense
you didn't even have a beer where'd that
come from buddy so I don't need to let
go but at the same time everything's
horrible anyway that I'm fired
you goddamn sock puppet nightmares all
boudoir get that oh come on oh come on
you intercepted that you [ __ ] ass hobby
da in oh [ __ ]
how but why is it tilting don't tilt
you're gonna get one why is it tilting
like it doesn't go fast if Oh far where
is that going someone just knocked that
into the sky and I don't appreciate it
Javed ah for you and not a golfer you
and okay all right I'm gonna go [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] [ __ ] me all right cool ha when you
had a light you hadn't no oh oh god I'm
gonna give you have a beer you had a
beer it's goddamn broken game this
broken game okay hi guys it's not broken
this game is great this game's well-made
great well done in your hand
Javed ah [ __ ] ha yes okay I'm in it to
win it now a little a good old righty
it's in it's literally in your hand it's
that was Indo okay it's okay though the
interception okay
ha ha ha Bebo oh [ __ ]
oh I was doing so good oh I don't know
where there's gonna be
it's job
whoa uh who are you ask hock [ __ ] poo me
oh [ __ ] okay here we go into your hand
this it's just a lie you're a liar okay
maybe maybe it's not a liar okay it just
needs care
why why why why don't you go that way
don't do that he no no aah fine you know
what I didn't want to serve you no why
why did that Kareem off into the abyss
and [ __ ] well that that creamed off
the abyss but for obvious reasons huh
bud up god damn you don't you nah just
pick it it's right there pick it up no
what the hell
look out god damn cocking hell oh [ __ ]
please please ass [ __ ] [ __ ] poo me why
you have an invisible wall in front of
you why you have an invisible all the
rid of you doesn't make any sense it
makes no sense
Oh shitty dicks okay all right we got
this is gonna be the one look how good I
am
look how good I am why you had your foot
it in your gob look down you're all
looking at me look at the beers coming
right out yeah hot and heavy [ __ ]
too hot too heavy like that movie too
fast too heavy too fast - [ __ ] - [ __ ]
please please give me a [ __ ] that I have
to give please ask [ __ ] [ __ ] me no just
give him the beer just give him the
goddamn oh just take it it's right in
front of your [ __ ] head you stole
that beer from that guy that was not
your beer and you didn't pay for that
alright um whap whap please ask [ __ ]
[ __ ] boo me I'm gonna do one more try
cuz I just
for punishment you have an invisible
wall in front of my makes no sense
y-yeah oh my god I'm so good no okay
that's broken a BA how about it buddy
how about no [ __ ] ass how about no oh
that was gonna be [ __ ] oh I hate this
goddamn game oh [ __ ] me [ __ ] me players
ass [ __ ] [ __ ] Bay
okay all right you know what you greedy
bastards oh you didn't even want one you
want one and now you don't have one all
right ah heck eek eek a mouse ache play
a [ __ ] please ask eek [ __ ] [ __ ] poo me
all right this is really spilling a
story out okay that didn't make any
sense
perfect okay not perfect but oh oh oh oh
it's all gone wrong there for me how
about one for me one for me bear for me
I get bear you don't get bear I get bear
not for you you don't get that beer you
don't get that bear you don't get that
bear not you not me me me all me me last
call for me
I need beer I can't drink beer I'm
drinking beer none for you all for me
all for me off whoopsie poopsie poopsie
poopsie / - poop see nobody get bare
nobody get bared nobody get bare how
about that how about nobody get bare how
about nobody get bare huh huh huh
how about nobody get bare okay well
please ask eat [ __ ] [ __ ] boo me got it
okay anyway I'm out of here so anyway
that was five weird games thank you
everybody so much for watching hope you
enjoyed that if you've got other oddball
games that you want me to play put them
in the description no you can't put them
in the description put them in the
comments down below because if sometimes
it's hard to find
truly weird games that truly mean games
if you got literally anything that you
want me to play as short and sweet and
can't be beat writing down the comments
if you want play anything that you saw
here you can find it in the description
that you can't write in it so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]